ladies and gentlemen welcome to the Tim
Dillon show uh we are it's migrant
crisis here in New York City
um there's a lot of uh migrants that are
coming in and
it's tough for everyone I guess I don't
know it's not it's it's not affected me
but it's bad and it's getting worse and
it's the new Ellis Island hundreds of
migrants flood into New York City's
Roosevelt Hotel
uh as Big Apple becomes epicenter of the
Border crisis and mayor Eric Adams says
he'll ask judge to suspend right to
shelter rules what the mayor's doing now
I think with a lot of the people that
are and this seems to be the biggest
issue that
uh the world is gonna face over the next
however many years
outside of climate and Technology the
biggest issue seems to be Mass migration
of people
from you know countries that are
unstable
to countries that are also unstable like
ours you know they're going to come from
uh a degree of instability to a to a a
more polished degree of instability but
this is going to be the biggest issue uh
it's the reason for brexit it's the
reason probably for uh a lot of the
political upheaval you see throughout
Europe
um this has been the issue that
everybody's talking about it's how many
immigrants migrants refugees whatever
the term is can a society absorb uh uh
before the society kind of buckles and
starts to break down and
um it's tough for New York because
everybody in New York
is predominantly pretty Progressive and
they all want to do the right thing and
but it this is uh you know people don't
like it they don't like it it becomes a
burden
and then you have like The Whispers
happening from all the good people that
want to do the right thing uh but they
start whispering about their block my R
Block has gotten
these are not people that would vote for
Trump these are not people that are
watching Fox News these are it's New
York and they live on the upper west
side of Manhattan
um but you know they put migrants in
hotels they put some of them
uh you know some of these new condos
that people spend a lot of money on a
part of the building is being utilized
for uh either low-income housing or to
kind of
house
um migrants that are coming in and then
people you know and you talk to real
estate agents they'll go you go that
building looks cool and they go oh no no
no no no no no no no no no they go not
that building they go that they
have low income housing they take the
same elevator so there's a lot of
whispering going on in uh in in those
areas in New York where people are uh uh
pretty upset that uh their neighborhoods
are seemingly uh being overrun with
people they don't recognize that's
becoming now they would never say that
publicly
and they take great pains to avoid
that uh you know characterization of it
they won't say that quite they'll be
like well it's just that's a lot of
people and you know they need help but
it's it's just it doesn't make sense and
I you know and so Eric Adams the mayor
has gotten hit on this they're putting
them in hotels they have been the
Roosevelt Hotel
um you know so now he's gonna ask the
right to shelter mandate he's gonna go
nope we do not have to provide housing
to people that need it
because New York has a mandate where
it's like if you ask for a bed we've got
to find you a bed
if you ask for housing we've got to give
you housing
um New York City
uh 11 000 Asylum Seekers went to Miami
15 000 went to LA no one even noticed uh
15 000 went to Houston and then forty
one thousand
came to New York City
and so now I think Eric Adams I think
the rule is now he's cut it down to like
60 days I think it's 30 to or 60 days in
the shelter so you you get here
you have nothing you know nobody you're
coming from a country that's in turmoil
and you have 60 days to figure New York
out
60 days
see this is why
you know
you lose Faith very quickly in the
people running things because at every
moment they make the worst decisions
like for example you might be against
New York City taking on
migrants but here's what you really
should be against
taking them on for 60 days and then
throwing them in the street
there couldn't be a worse policy than
taking people for 60 days and then
telling them that they hopefully they
figured it out
well you've had 60 days have you learned
the language do you have a job
you have a down payment saved can you
work they're not even going to get a
work permit in 60 days they're set up
for failure
they're set up to go into
to be homeless or to to do some type of
crime to just survive
so it's weird and there's a backlash
because people are like listen man
you know this is going to make it worse
uh the Roosevelt Hotel the Paul Hotel
and the Paramount Hotel or among the
hotels designated for housing migrants
in Manhattan
there's long lines of migrants mostly
men from Africa
are now often seen outside the story
locations and this is what people are
not digging
they don't dig a bunch of people in
their community that are on the street
long lines you know people start to
notice they go what's going on starting
to look a little third world but they
don't they whisper that they don't say
it loudly they go I just I you know I'm
I try to understand
you know these poor people and I I feel
sorry for them there's lots of
restaurants in Manhattan right now where
you say oh a white woman with a glass of
wine going I think this is horrible
what's happening to these people but I
just don't know what good it is having
them stand outside of this hotel up my
block I don't know how does it help them
and of course there are the people that
are being uh very uh vocal about this
there are protesters who are surrounding
the Roosevelt Hotel where Eric Adams is
housing hundreds of migrants and then
screaming send them back which is this
is unnecessary I think I don't know what
if this helps but there are people
screaming send them back uh let's let's
see this clip
it's not a lot of people
yeah so this is not
this is not ideal and uh
[Applause]
but it's it's uh they're angry they're
angry and they're unhappy and uh there's
nothing more they can uh do except a
yell
and um is Curtis Lee went out involved
this guy well Curtis Sliwa by the way is
one of the famous criminals in New York
Liars
um who's made up fake instances of crime
that he solved people saved people from
um he's a colorful character but he's uh
you know he just makes up it's a
little Hassan Minaj action where it's
like he believes in the emotional truth
of the scenario and let's see what uh he
has to say he's always excited when
there's something he doesn't have to
make up Curtis Sliwa he literally made
up stories uh of crimes on the subway
that were happening where he would jump
in and save people with his group the
guardian angels so now he gets really
excited when there's real news and he is
he's a mayoral candidate and he's angry
about the migrants and what let's see
what his solution is
we will
make for what they have done to us
day and our country America president
[Applause]
it's so funny you see like there's like
an old hippie holding the no mic the the
greatest uh thing you've seen over the
last like I don't know let's say
four years has been like hippies
becoming Die Hard Republicans like old
like Ben and Jerry's style protesting
the Vietnam War hippies are now at these
marches with like the America First
People certainly it's it's a long life
many of those hippies who lived to this
point have now gone uh right wing I
don't know what this does I don't think
this helps anybody
uh screaming send them back and no
migrants these people have nothing
and one of the reasons they have nothing
is that we went around the world
destabilizing a lot of their countries
we went around pursuing this crazy
policy of like regime change in Libya in
Syria all these places that have sent
boatloads of people into Europe This is
not news to anyone that doesn't mean
that we can take in the entire world but
I don't the complexity of that seems to
be lost on these people that are in the
street with signs as it usually is
um
and the migrants what's funny is the
migrants are actually the ones that are
in the hotels it was an article I think
it was in the post and they're they're
talking about uh they're talking about
how unhappy they are with the food they
like any everything else but they're
basically like hey like this one woman
goes we came here uh she's a Russian she
goes we came here to avoid mobilization
for the war said Leela usmanov who fled
Russia with her husband and she goes we
have three kids 16 10 and three
we don't want to fight against our own
ukrainians or Russians same people she
goes we're grateful to the US government
but complain that the food the city was
providing at the Swanky Hotel turned
shelter was less than nutritious my
husband and I have high blood sugar and
the food isn't very good for us our kids
don't want to eat it
she also added come here in the evening
and you will see a giant pile of wasted
food they're throwing out 90 of the food
here isn't eaten well welcome to America
welcome this is uh you're gonna get
poisoned they're gonna get put another
guy goes you've been here three months
it's only temporary until I could get a
work permit and find some work all I
want to do is start working and build a
life
he said of the shelter this is a huge
help it's clean it's safe but then he
goes on as well to complain about the
food he goes they're good with the kids
they're very attentive but he goes You
Know listen we can't eat the food here
he goes it's it's not good it's not good
for our kids
um you know he goes we don't have a
kitchen the food isn't good for the kids
we would rather make our own food so
everybody all of these uh migrants by
the way these are the most desperate
people on the planet at the moment they
have nothing they have nothing and their
main problem is American Cuisine that's
how bad the food is in this country
that's a absolutely terrible the food is
in this country they would rather starve
or go hungry than eat the food and and
God only knows what we're providing them
by the way God only knows what they're
getting we're probably giving them pop
arts and chicken nuggets they
are getting
what we feed our children I mean it's
not something that we don't feed our own
kids but they're so horrified which is
again it's like this should wake
Americans up like Americans should get
woken up by this they should go the most
desperate people in the world refuse to
eat our food they can't eat the food
they go this is poison how is everyone
eating this this is actually poison
and Americans have been so desensitized
and people a lot of people have just
given up and when you have a family you
got to feed them and you got to go to
grocery stores you gotta buy this
whatever Tyson churns out or
whatever Dole or whatever these
companies are doing you gotta buy it but
it's so hilarious to me that people that
are here for like five minutes eat it
and they spit it out they go no no this
is poison we can't we can't give this to
our children this is crazy and uh you
know it's I this is like when we drop
those care packages on Afghanistan while
they were blowing we were blowing them
up and we dropped like you know fun dip
and Pop-Tarts on Afghans and they were
like go for it don't worry about the war
we got you covered here we go and we're
just bombing them with Reese's Peanut
Butter Cups and all of those people were
just entirely like what the is it
if you give our food to anyone else no
matter how bad their lot in life is if
you give our food to anyone they're
stunned they're shocked by it they can't
even believe it they don't if you bring
people over here and these people aren't
from Europe it's not like they were
living in France they're not wealthy
there's about people that lived in an
Italian Villa these are people that were
ran out of their country by a flood or a
crazy government and they're still going
what the are you giving our
children to eat they care more than
people that live in this country about
the food they care more
on Sunday the post reported that at
least 41 migrants have been arrested on
charges including domestic violence at
The Roosevelt Hotel shelter on East 45th
that's well this is the food this is
what happens uh with the food
well this isn't good it's not good when
people start beating each other up
you're you just got here you gotta wait
a little bit to start hitting your wife
you have to wait you can't just go right
into hitting your wife uh it's it's not
gonna work
it's a bad situation they've known about
how bad this is for a while
uh and they didn't they don't really
report on it now it's gotten so bad that
the dam is about to break so like every
newspaper in New York City is going what
do we do
let's talk about how long they're giving
them now I mean look at this this is
great somebody defended the meal saying
the migrants were well fed we give them
really good food here vegetables
nutritious stuff
these people don't know what good food
is they're we give them great food here
we give them vegetables
it's nutritious I'm telling you if you
saw what we're feeding these people
I don't know what it is but it it should
be a wake-up call for everybody in this
country with a family who's feeding
their children how bad uh things are
getting out there
how bad it is with the food that people
that were literally being beaten in
other countries are
commenting now none of these people have
work permits none of them could work
and and now Eric Adams is saying they're
only there for 30 minutes
I'm sorry 30 days
30 days and then they're out
and then they're gone and they're on the
street
and
it's like what are they supposed to do
30 days in City run facilities
30.
that's it and then and then good luck
and then you're just here now
you're just here like everybody else
trying to figure it out so they're
dumping thousands of migrants onto the
street soon by the way this is coming
soon this is coming like the next uh few
weeks
the mayor called the move another step
in our effort to help Asylum Seekers
take the next step in their Journeys
what if what what it what is he talking
about the next step in their Journey
I mean is this like a a self-help book
The Next Step In Their Journey that's
the type of language you use for like
middle class white kids
whose parents are like asking them to
leave because they're 27 and they need
to start their own life these
people have no idea what the hell to do
this is the most expensive city in
America
how the are they gonna survive they
have to take the next step in their
journey and really start to listen to
themselves and self-actualize and
basically figure out what they want to
do and who are you on the inside I mean
this is not the language you use for
people that are at the lowest point in
their life that have nothing
this is not the language you use this is
the language that is used for people
that have been coddled and privileged
their entire life and you're like listen
buddy I I mean that's like when my
friend was getting kicked out of his
house by his parents who were like it's
time that you get the out of here
they said like that literally they
were like it's time to take the next
step in your journey it's your journey
and it's time to take the next step and
it's exciting and and by the way his
mother used to be like it's exciting and
he'd stare at him and she goes exciting
you should be excited you're about to
step out there in the world and have
your own life it's like what are these
people going to do
don't speak English they come from
countries where they're allowed to hit
their wife and now they're here and
they're getting arrested for domestic
violence imagine that imagine the shock
of a behavior that is absolutely allowed
not saying it's good but it's absolutely
loud and in those countries when the
wife steps out of line she gets
reprimanded this is not right this is
what happens now they come here and they
get arrested for domestic violence are
completely thrown they're completely
thrown I'm sure there's good people that
aren't hitting their wives
but this is just a different culture and
the idea that like we're talking to them
like this she's uh they're 23 year olds
that just graduated Oberlin College it's
time to take the next step in your
journey it's your journey it's like a
woman who's there with a big black and
blue on her eye and we just arrested her
husband for domestic violence and she's
like I actually need him to pay some of
these bills I don't really work I cook
and I get hit that's what I do I don't
work so can you get him back because now
I'm I I kind of you know
you know it's it's it's weird
seeing these like these are the worst
policies possible
and the worst way to handle the
situation if you want to take people in
you have to give them and I know people
are going to hate me saying this you
have to give them a minimum of like six
months you can't cannot happen in one
month
and if you're gonna do it I'm not saying
even this right to do I'm not even
saying that we can do it but if you're
gonna do it
my I I couldn't figure this city out I'm
a white guy I I came from a a a
community that was 45 minutes outside of
New York it took me years to figure out
New York City where I could survive
and that's a guy that spoke the language
able-bodied worked and it was still
tough it was still like apartment to
apartment room to room it's brutally
expensive very difficult
and now we're basically telling these
people who just got here
we're basically saying to them
in 60 days we're gonna stop feeding you
we're gonna kick you out of the hotel
and I know it sucks
to stay in the hotel with all the
migrants I know it sucks I'm gonna be
honest with you I know it's not fun
I know it's not fun
I get it I'm not one of these people
that's gonna pretend that it's fun when
you're living in an apartment building
you spend a shitload of money on your
apartment and you're or your condo or
whatever it is and then it's being
overrun by people nobody likes that
doesn't matter who they are by the way
it doesn't matter if they were college
kids from Nashville if they were white
college kids from Nashville they were
throwing uh parties or whatever they
were doing they were being loud they
were nobody would want it New York is
about escaping from people when you can
on the street you can't it's mobbed on
the subway you can't it's mob there's
nothing for you to do
but when you go back to your own space
that you pay dearly for you just don't
want people in your space people hate
other people can we get back to that
people truly they like the idea of other
people they like a few people but they
don't like a lot of people that they
don't know no one likes that I live in a
building where you know I spend part of
my time here I walk out you know my no
one makes eye contact nobody looks at
each other
nobody acknowledges each other because
what's the point
that's the real what is the point of
acknowledging this stranger in the hall
there is no point we're not going to be
good friends we're not going to spend
holidays together we're not going to
care if the other one is found dead none
of that's gonna matter and we know that
New York is
Tough by Design and the people that live
here
you know they put up some walls and
they're like listen I gotta work I gotta
survive I like the things the city
provides but I don't have the time
to emotionally invest in every single
person I meet and that's different if
you live in the south you live in other
places where you meet so many fewer
people that they become more important
in New York you're constantly passing
people in the hallway of your building
on a train in the lobby of your office
building you can't invest emotionally in
all of these people so it is a city
where people just
you know they they kind of keep to
themselves to a degree
so this idea that you're just gonna
throw all these migrant families into
condominiums or hotels and that it's
going to work out
and the people are going to be excited
about it's not true it's not true
um you know and I I just don't think
this was well thought out
and it's gonna get worse because now
they're on the street now you're gonna
put them on the street
because no one has any idea what to do
nobody has any idea what to do there's
enough space in this country but they
can't be here
they cannot be here
and I know that people are going to go
well isn't that a little that's a little
hypocritical because New York is pretty
liberal and you say yeah of course I
understand that
if we're gonna take him in we gotta put
him somewhere else
we got it we have so I was in Iowa
recently
and I was just driving and thank you to
everyone who came out to that casino and
I was just driving and it was just corn
fields and
hey
I'm I'm I'm not saying
that
you know I'm not trying to
dump our problem on aisle but put it put
him there put him there
put them in the Great Plains put them in
areas where there's nothing
and you know let them do what they do
and we we just can't deal with it here
can't happen here
I think we should do a moratorium on all
this stuff I don't think we could really
take that many people in anymore I think
it's going to completely destroy
the fabric of society because what's
gonna happen is
people
are going to start
feeling fearful
of
the rapidly changing environment they
live in and when that happens people
then become
very readily
um
willing to
start bringing in very Draconian
measures
to ensure their safety and their family
safety and if you like living in a free
Society like if you like a society
that's free where you're not hassled all
the time people are not asking you for
information all the time there's not
checkpoints everywhere you're not living
in this dystopian horror show you have
to put a limit on the amount of people
that you can absorb because the more and
more people that come in the more more
fearful full people are the more the
crime rate goes up the more homelessness
becomes
um more apparent around them people are
going to say let's do it I'm for it
let's get the checkpoints let's start
asking people for their papers let's
start doing all this stuff we got to
figure out who's who
you know and and it's more and more
security measures that will be
instituted and there's nothing you could
do
there's nothing really to do other than
that if you're going to let everybody in
if you're going to let everybody in
you're gonna have to have more cops
more security
and it's going to feel a lot less free
which is not good
maybe they'll leave when the if once
they realize the food is not changing
and the corporations that own the
companies that make the food will not be
changing
so maybe after a few months in New York
City Schools when their kids are 300
pounds and they come back and they say
actually I'm non-binary now maybe
they'll go we gotta go home maybe and
maybe that's why it's actually good the
country's in the state it's in
maybe you shouldn't change the schools
maybe you should start sex changes on
these migrant family kids immediately so
that they go oh we gotta get the
out of here
I love Helix mattresses anyone that
comes and visits my house goes what
mattress is that and then they all get
them I'm telling you I've had my
mattress for a couple years my sleep has
improved everybody loves it they offer
20 unique mattresses including the
award-winning Luxe collection that's
what I have the newly released Helix
Elite collection a mattress designed for
Big and Tall sleepers and even a
mattress made just for kids so how will
you know which Helix mattress works best
for you and your body take the Helix
sleep quiz and find your perfect
mattress in under two minutes and your
personalized mattress is shipped right
to your door free of charge Helix knows
there's no better way to test out a new
mattress than by sleeping on it in your
own home that's why they offer 100 night
trial and at 10 to 15 year warranty to
try out your new Helix mattress and if
your spa needs to measure TLC they got
you every Helix mattress has a hybrid
design combining individually wrapped
steel coils in the base with premium
foam layers on top it's a perfect
combination of comfort and support
Helix is offering 20 off all mattresses
orders and two free pillows for our
listeners go to helixsleep.com timd and
use code Helix partner 20. this is their
best offer and it won't last long 20 off
all mattress orders and two free pillows
for our listeners go and use the code
Helix partner 20. best offer yet won't
last long with Helix better sleep starts
now 400 pound NYPD robot gets tryout in
Times Square subway station the K5
described as fully autonomous security
robot as part of a push by the mayor for
more law enforcement technology with I
mean this folks this you know if we're
gonna have if you're gonna put bring
more and more people in get ready for
the bot and the security robot and by
the way I just try to get on the good
side of these things they're not going
away they're not going away you couldn't
scream and yell about the autonomous bot
that will now Patrol the subway your
only job if you live in New York is to
get on the good side of the bot because
that's not going away that there's no
look how happy that cop is standing next
to that bot look how thrilled he is that
they can blame someone else besides him
they will that bot will start pushing
people onto the sub way tracks and look
how thrilled the cut they're all happy
with the but this is all they've wanted
since the George Floyd stuff they just
go just bring in the machines please
please someone else to blame bring in
the Bots bring in the autonomous
bringing the K5 whatever they call it
they're thrilled if if you're a cop in
this city this is your partner now this
is who you blame everything on oh my God
you're gonna be like no no this is the
K5 okay this is the K5 there's not going
to be uh a situation by the way where
this will not be used they are gonna use
this for everything it's starting in the
subway but then it'll be on the street
it's gonna be on the street it's you're
just gonna see it it's gonna go it's
gonna go by it's gonna turn around and
look at you it's gonna do like a sensor
thing and then it's gonna decide what
it's gonna do
so try to get on the good side of the K5
bot if you can
um because
you know Mark radlin a restaurant
manager says it looks like an oversized
version of R2D2 a Droid from the Star
Wars films I don't know what it's
supposed to be
I don't know what it's supposed to be it
looks like a trash can on Wheels stop
insulting it stop on it I'm
telling you
stop
it's from a california-based maker night
scope
night scope describes it as a quote
fully autonomous outdoor security robot
a fully autonomous outdoor security
robot it's currently used in hospitals
malls airports warehouses and casinos
and it will soon be deployed to Times
Square subway station the city's busiest
underground Transit Hub it's armed with
four cameras it will record video but
not audio it will employ facial
recognition at uh you know so they're
just gonna they're gonna be able to
identify you immediately
and it's about the cost of leasing it
averages out to about nine dollars per
hour nice and cheap
our mayor the good Eric Adams says this
is below minimum wage no bathroom breaks
no meal breaks
they're all in on the bot they're all in
on it they are thrilled they're good
because cops are quitting now cops got I
don't want to do this or you know
some cities are are are allocating some
of the police budget somewhere else and
now we have the fully autonomous bot
who can do facial recognition on you
I see the bot can't
the Bots this is the first step the
first stage of the bot
the bot can't restrain you yet
the bot can't do anything to you yet
this is the first bot the bot will only
get better and night scope don't think
knightscope didn't have that
conversation don't think knightscope
didn't go by the way this is only the
demo this is only our first bot we have
bots in production that can do things
you know all the cops and Eric Adams are
sitting in a in a conference room and
night scope whatever the hell that is
based in California night scope has a
video monitor on the wall and it's just
Transformer style Bots pinning people to
the wall and chucking them and
I'm telling you the cops are ear to ear
Smiles Eric Adams is like and how much
will these guys do this for they're like
it's nine an hour we can maybe get it
down to six maybe the Bots that attack
people will be 15. maybe the Bots that
have the full capacity to restrain
people that might be 15. but they're all
sitting there they're all very excited
because they know this is just the
beginning they know it's just the
beginning and don't think it's uh by the
way it's any type of coincidence that we
have this migrant crisis and now we have
the Bots coming in because all you
people need to accept the pot and the
only way they're going to accept the bot
is if they're going to their house and
they see all of these people lurking in
the streets and now they're going to be
intense they're desperate we've thrown
them out of the hotels they don't know
what to do they're desperate they're
hungry they can't get any services from
the government what are they going to do
they're going to go well that lady's got
a pocketbook that guy might have a
wallet and things could get dicey and
that's when they start going and here
are the Bots here are the Bots and uh
yeah I just wish I could have been a fly
on the wall for the meeting when they
went into the NYPD and they said meet
your new partner K-5
and those guys are like yeah but what
could K5 really do he's got facial
recognition you know and they go yeah
this is the first generation they go you
know iPhones right in the cops are like
yeah I know iPhones you know how when
the first one came out it couldn't do
much didn't really have a great camera
you know you couldn't do much and then
every generation of the phone got better
and better and better and more capable
and now you can't live without your
phone if you don't have your phone even
for several minutes you freaked the
out
that's what we're gonna do with the bot
every generation of the K5 what do you
think the K7 is going to do it's the K5
can identify you on the street and can
use facial recognition to know who you
are what do you think the K7 what about
the K9 the K9 should be one that looks
like a dog for fun
what do you think the canines gonna do
the K10
I mean if you all live long enough
you'll live long enough to see the k-15
now the k-15s job is to basically sense
you're gonna commit a crime before you
commit it and then get you down and then
deactivate you on the street before
you're able to do anything
it's it's uh terrifying but you gotta
embrace it so get on the good side
because it's not going away get on the
good side of the K5 however you're gonna
do it pet it rub it when you walk in go
hello okay fot like just start being
obedient
to the fully autonomous security bot in
the subway start being obedient and
maybe he'll record because he's gonna
record everything by the way they're
gonna record your reactions they have
facial recognition they know exactly who
you are so if you're like one of these
people that's like you K5 the KA is
gonna remit they're gonna pull the file
up as soon as they see you when they're
gonna go oh that guy was really nice to
K5 he was kind of a he called K5 a
he spit on K5 that wasn't really
nice I think this guy's a problem I
think this guy needs a little attitude
adjustment he was very nasty him and his
friends actually kicked K5 for no
goddamn reason I'm K-8 poor K5 didn't
know how to handle these guys I know K8
knows exactly what to do so whatever you
do around these Bots just know it will
be recorded for future use it will
absolutely be recorded it's going into a
database any anti-social behavior that
you display around K5 is going to be
remembered by K9 K10 and k11. they're
going to be able to pull it up and go
you know what
you weren't really a team player when we
rolled out our little brother K5 were
you no we actually pulled up your file
and we just watched some of your
behavior and you know what we're not
excited they'll follow you home they're
gonna follow you home they'll follow you
home it's it this is all happening this
is all happening you may not like it but
it's all gonna happen so my advice to
you while you can get in good with K5 if
I ever see K5 I'm going to just be like
hello K5 thank you for coming to our
city I love you K5 look at K5 and go I
love you K5 because that's gonna get
saved they are going to record
everything that you do and they're go
and all the generations of the security
Bots will remember it
if they're gonna remember it so just
know that Mr Adams who once patrolled
the Subways as a Transit cop was elected
on a promise to reduce crime without
violating New Yorkers civil rights he
supports using technology to enhance law
enforcement the mayor returned in August
from a trip to Israel always good news
where he saw how law enforcement there
uses drones in conjunction with
motorcycle and I love by the way that we
go to Israel Israel and Palestine have
been fighting forever and ever they have
a very tense security situation and it
should not be the model for our country
our country should not we should not
model anything after the Gaza Strip
there's no way that we should model
policing in Columbus Ohio after the most
volatile region in the world so whenever
anybody gets back from a trip to Israel
the most volatile region in the world
and they were there to talk about
security that's no good that's not good
they come back and they're like well
we've I mean listen you take El Al the
airline and it is you it is the most
secure you ever feel flying because they
do these crazy and it's understandable
because they've lived with this threat
of political instability and terrorism
for a very very long time right not
notwithstanding their their role in that
I'm not going into that right now what
I'm saying is that modeling our security
situation after the most volatile place
in the world is only going to get
everybody's civil rights snatched away
Mr Adams is also a promoted proponent of
digidog a robotic dog that is deployed
in emergency situations such as building
collapses
there's nothing better in a building
collapse than a robotic dog
we've all seen digidog there's digidog
right there so Digi dog
by the way notice how all this stuff
they're all lying all the time they're
like uh Digi dog is for the building
collapse what does anyone believe that
does anyone believe the only time you're
gonna see digidog is in the
once every 10-year building how many
buildings are collapsing in the city
that you need an army of digital dogs
but this is the way the Press is writing
it up they're like no did you dogs here
for the tsunami
and the building collapses and uh if
there's uh you know the earthquakes at
New York City uh experiences once every
400 years that's that's why we have
digidog no no no we have a fully
autonomous robot dog
for the building collapse so that if
you're in the rubble of a building that
has just collapsed and you are comforted
by this uh Digi dog
so it's not going to do anything else
so Digi dog's not gonna do it you smoke
a weed on a park bench did you dog's not
gonna show up out of nowhere
digidog's not gonna show up
is that is that what we believe there's
gonna be no Digi dog in other situations
I think there might be I think digidog
might find his way out of the building
collapse and into your life but notice
how this is all brought out it's all
brought out in a very positive helpful
let's see we're saving money we're
saving money and there's building
collapses and don't you want to get
saved by a digital dog watch this
article New York City officials unveiled
three new high policing devices Tuesday
including a robotic dog that critics
called creepy
when it was first debuted two and a half
years ago the new devices which also
include a GPS tracker for stolen cars
and a cone-shaped security robot will be
rolled out in a manner that is
transparent consistent and always done
in close collaboration with the people
we serve
digidog is out of the pound said Eric
Adams a Democrat thank God our man this
is what happens when the mayor's on coke
and you could just hand the mayor an
eight ball and go sit down we got a lot
of cool stuff we're about to show you
he's sitting there he's like
did your dog is now part of the tool kit
that we are using by the way is there
any is there anything worse than that by
the way all you need is to not let
criminals out of jail you need bail laws
that actually makes sense you need areas
to be adequately policed you need cops
to be uh adequately trained we've all
decided we can't do any of that we've
all decided we can't do any of that
bring on K5 and digidog by the way
because we've decided we can't do it we
can't train police we can't tell them to
just not shoot innocent black people in
the face we can't figure out a way to
give criminals the appropriate amount of
bails none of this can be done it it
can't be done we've given up it's not
going to work human beings have failed
it's not going to happen what's going to
happen is we're gonna bring on robots
and digital dogs and that's gonna be the
way we're gonna do it
a few loud people were opposed to it and
we took a step back the mayor said this
is not how I operate I operate on
looking at what's best for the city
Adam said that the remote controlled
70-pound digidog will be deployed in
Risky situations like hostage standoff
starting this summer if you have a
barricaded suspect if you have someone
that's inside a building that is armed
instead of sending police there you're
going to send digidog so when they're
rolling all this stuff out they have to
describe all of these crazy situations
that barely if ever it never happened
it's like uh when we had the ticking
Time Bomb scenario when we were just
torturing people randomly in underground
prisons and we were going yeah but the
ticking time bomb and then they made the
sum of all fears that dumb movie and
we're gonna buy with a nuke the baseball
game well it's the ticking Time Bomb
situation because there's the nuke and
there's this guy this limo driver knows
where the nuke is and we gotta torture
him so we can find out what would you do
in a ticking Time Bomb so they always
arrange this stuff so that you think
well this is of course this is NASA of
course why wouldn't we have a Labyrinth
of secret portrait prisons why wouldn't
that make sense
there it's a ticking Time Bomb scenario
would you use I remember when I was
growing up like people were running for
president they would ask John Kerry
they'd be like wouldn't you use torture
if there was a ticking Time Bomb
scenario now by the way we all know in a
ticking Time Bomb scenario this country
Would Do Anything by the way we would do
anything
um at all it's it's crazy to even think
that we would like hold back in that
rare so far imaginary scenario
of a ticking Time Bomb the idea that we
wouldn't torture somebody with a ticking
time is hilarious but this is like the
way they're rolling that digital they're
like well you know this
hostage standoff uh police
first of all ditchy dog again
someone killed there Digi dog doesn't
care you're supposed to have a hostage
negotiate did anyone stop this idiot
mayor and go uh actually uh mayor Adams
you're supposed to have a hostage
negotiator who talks to the person who's
holding the person hostage not a a dog
you're not supposed to send a robot dog
we weren't sending real dogs to high
were we sending canines into hostage
negotiation situations yeah you got a
bunch of hostages send in the Shepherds
no one was doing that nobody was doing
that you're supposed to send it a human
being who's trained in this tactic which
is very difficult of getting someone to
walk out of that building without
killing anyone or themselves
and now they're like well
the tracking system called star Chase
will allow police to launch a GPS tag
that will attach itself to a stolen cars
that officers can track the vehicle's
location
okay well that's fine
I don't have a problem with people not
getting a car stolen the autonomous
security robot which atoms compared to a
Roomba will be deployed inside the Times
Square subway station in a seven month
pilot program starting this summer
the device is already being used in
shopping centers and it'll be first
joined by a human partner that's great
that's good news
so K5 is going to have some racists from
Staten Island teaching them all about
okay five you see these people they're
different you better watch them
American royalty tour is on the road
right now we are in Des Moines Iowa
Omaha Nebraska Sacramento California
then we're heading to Australia Perth
Adelaide Sydney Brisbane Melbourne New
Zealand Auckland Christchurch then
Rochester New York New York New York
Carnegie Hall Pittsburgh Pennsylvania
Houston Texas Detroit Michigan Toronto
Ontario Brea California for New Year's
we're announcing dates in Boston and DC
and some other places coming up if you
live in any of these cities go to Tim
dilloncomedy.com grab tickets back to
the show Harvard Westlake which is an
elite school in La where a lot of rich
kids and famous people have gone uh it's
very sad uh it's like the school of
choice for the elite of La drive by it
all the time
three three children have died by
Suicide unfortunately in the past
six months
and uh
it's very difficult
um to be a teenager in the age of social
media
and there's all these studies coming out
now about how bad social media is for
children especially when they're
developing
uh the first was a girl in the sophomore
class
a few months later a senior boy a third
a rising Junior
took himself out during the summer
I mean people were freaking out says one
Alum they were calls to cancel the
school year but they didn't
quote it's tragic but not terribly
surprising that students are feeling
pressured from academic expectations and
this whole La lifestyle
you know it's difficult
it's a difficult the more recent alums
are colder than they are
like they've had a hard life there's a
tremendous amount of pressure I think on
certain kids my parents put very little
pressure on me which also not great
um but many kids uh their Excellence is
demanded of them because the family they
come from or
and they end up not being able to some
kids really care what their parents
think about them God
and that's lovely that's maybe kind of
sweet it really is like they really care
about Legacy and expectations and I've
let my father down and I I mean there
was there's nothing I can relate to less
than that
there's not anything I can relate to
less than that thing of like letting my
parents I never cared I was always like
I'm doing my own thing and
win or lose it is what it is my life
completely I'm not upholding any but
there are kids out there
that live in the shadow of their parents
and they can't handle it and a lot of
them probably go to that school
and their parents are I mean it's tragic
listen anytime somebody as a teenager
takes their life it's still I I'm not
even gonna make a joke about it because
it is that up and sad
and the the you know the parents are
probably going through hell and and you
know probably a lot of them are going we
put too much pressure
on the students and listen this you know
if you are rich it doesn't necessarily
mean you are happy
and if you are if your parents are rich
it doesn't necessarily mean your home
life is good
in fact
really the happiest people I know were
always middle class people people that
weren't broke but also weren't loaded
that way they they life had consequences
it had meaning you know their decisions
meant something
um but they weren't desperate
but they didn't have an endless supply
of money they didn't have a legacy name
to uphold
they weren't like
you know characters in a movie they were
allowed to be full human beings and when
you're a teenager that's really
important
um
it's tough to get into an Ivy League
school these days
and it's tough and a lot of times if you
don't get into an Ivy League school
you let your family down
and they're upset and maybe they're not
even
outwardly upset it's just kind of like a
disappointment my friend who's a rich
kid said the thing about those families
is there's not a lot of raw emotion
that comes out a lot of it is kind of
this passive aggressive quiet
disappointment that eats at you even
more than if someone was like what the
is wrong with you
they just don't do that a lot of these
people are not built to have that type
of
emotional release
so they just hold everything in
and again I'm not I don't know why these
three kids did this I'm only
extrapolating is this La mag
they're extrapolating too
I know the community of Harvard West
Lake is struggling to find a reason said
Richard Lieberman the lead Suicide
Prevention expert for the public school
system in LA and that is the struggle of
survivors but no one person and no one
thing is ever to blame for suicide
perhaps
perhaps but
maybe there is I don't know
it's very difficult I think in the next
few years if like as a country we're
going to have to cut out
some of the social media man for
children it's it's going to get really
bad I think if you don't do that and you
don't start taking control over what
your kids watch
they're going to end up in this position
where you know they're incredibly
depressed they're incredibly anxious
and you got there's there's two things
you could do with your kids you gotta
either kind of pull them off this stuff
or you got to make them really hot
really cool
truly
if you're gonna let them you know what
you got to make it really hot and really
cool you gotta make them into a
product you gotta make them into the
Envy of all the world you do and if you
have the patience to do that you have
the skill set to turn your children into
the coolest people
that's one thing that many people don't
many people are just working they don't
have the time and it's unfortunate
because their kids are going to go on
social media and eventually some of them
are going to off themselves and that's
terrible
so if you have the opportunity to sit
down with your kids and go listen we got
to get you to a place where I feel
comfortable sending you out into this
world not being a total loser I
got to feel comfortable sending you into
this world
someone who's cool
and who's respected and people like that
way you're not going to end up in this
situation
I don't know but these people seem cool
these people seem cool
that's a thing right
none of my friends have off themselves
it is shocking I am so shocked that none
of my friends have shot themselves in
the head do you know how many reasons
there are for a lot of people I know to
off themselves
I mean
thousands and yet none of them have done
it none of them have done it
and these three kids at a Prep
School in L.A probably about to have
great lives
so to me that says social media
and that says
maybe family Dynamics are a big problem
maybe chemical depression or whatever
but nobody I know nobody I know not one
person not one person
that I know has taken their own life and
that says a lot that says a lot
because there's ample reasons for a lot
of people I know to not be here anymore
and they are still here and they are
still texting and they are still
concerning themselves with nonsense and
it would be you know understandable it's
I'm not I don't want it to happen God
forbid but it would be it would be so
understandable the response to many of
my friends all of themselves would be
this well of course
that would be the response of course so
this is actually really creepy
and it points to the fact that we've got
this very destructive force in society
that is making kids depressed it's
making them anxious it's telling them
everybody hates them there's cyber
bullying they're looking at other
people's lives that are better they're
making themselves crazier than they are
there's bipolar influencers now I mean
there's borderline personality
influencers that's a that's a genre of
the internet now there are people that
are getting clout based on the
exploration of their borderline
personality disorder and then there's
people that don't have borderline
personality disorder convincing
themselves that they do
you know I mean I know a guy on
Instagram he's an eczema influencer I
kid you not he's a hot guy
he's a hot dude on igne he has eczema
and he just pulls his hand out and he
goes a lot of people don't know what
eczema is or a lot of people confuse
eczema with something else and a lot of
people are just like hey man why is your
hand up it's like dude just put
cream on it the rest of you is fine what
is this but it's his relatability to
people because he's a hot guy and he's
going what do I what am I going to talk
about and you know you can think about
Fitness maybe you're brilliant and you
talk about politics or whatever I don't
know but he's going I guess I'll do
eczema
so he's got his red hand up it's going
like yeah people are calling me lizard
hand but like here's what eczema is and
so all of these things
all of these people when you're young
you're impressionable you're looking at
this you're looking at the borderline
personality influence you may be
convincing yourself that things are
worse than they are
especially if you're 15 years old you
may be on the internet go maybe things
are worse than they are maybe I have
this maybe I have that maybe I'm all
over the place and you might your
parents might need to just get involved
and really shut it off kids should not
have phones in school number one they
should go in Yonder bags like comedy
clubs kids should not be on their phones
in school all day that's crazy
kids should have social media limited
Big Time parents should kind of get more
involved as to what their kids are
looking at online
and I'm not saying it's bad the people
that have mental health struggles are
sharing those struggles on the internet
I'm saying that when you take Mental
Health
and then you take the need for clout
social acceptance all of these things
status and you merge them you can have a
big problem you want to belong you join
a community doesn't mean you should be
in the community but you're in it
you're 15 you're like hey man I might be
in this this might be my bag I might be
with the borderline kids borderline gang
it that's maybe what's going on
we didn't know how up we were
when we were kids that that was good we
didn't know I up we could have
been diagnosed with a million things
we could have been diagnosed with a
million things we barely knew how
up we were we didn't know and that it's
very interesting that a lot of the
people
that I was surrounded myself with
figured out some type of life because
they weren't burdened from their
youngest age thinking about all the
ailments they might have well the
psychological conditions that were
available to them as a means to
potentially belonging or joining a group
that doesn't mean people don't have
legit psychological problems but it does
mean that like you know at the end of
the day it's like
let's you know maybe it's a doctor that
should diagnose you maybe you shouldn't
be diagnosing yourself on the tick tock
discover page but it's really sad
um what happened to those three uh
children at
Harvard Westlake it is
sad I I do I am aware that poor children
also die but I don't care